Uh, how do I explain Deuteronomy 18:18
to a Muslim that says that this is about
Muhammad? Say, hold on. So, Deuteronomy
18 is prophesying Muhammad, right? Yes.
Since you quoted the book, Since you
quoted the book,
that
means the prophet like Moses won't
contradict the theology of the book,
right?
Because you got to get them agree. So,
Deuteronomy 18:18 is about Muhammad,
right? They'll say, "Yeah." So since you
just quoted the book, that means if
Muhammad is the prophet like Moses, he's
not going to contradict the teaching
theology of Deuteronomy. Right?
Now, do me a favor. Open up your Bible.
Just go to Deuteronomy 14:1.
Deuteronomy 14.
[Music]
Deuteronomy 14 verse1.
Got it. Read it for me.
I have the king. So the king ain't on it
if the king ain't in it.
You are the children of the Lord your
God. You shall not cut yourselves nor
make any baldness between your eyes for
the dead. Okay. According to
Deuteronomy, the true God is a spiritual
father. He's not a physical being. He
doesn't have sex. He's a spiritual
father to Israel. Israel, the Israelites
are the sons and daughters of God,
right?
Mhm. No Muslim believes Allah is a
father to Muhammad or
anyone. Okay? If you're going to debate
Muslims, you got to learn their
theology. You got to learn their
theology. You can't just go in there
being ignorant of what they believe.
Right?
Okay. No Muslim, no Muslim thinks Allah
is the father, the father of mother or
anyone because Allah is a father to no
one. You with me there?
Yes. Okay. So, you got to know their
theology or you're not going to be able
to refute them. So, Allah is not a
father to anyone. He's not the father of
Muhammad. He's not the father of
Muslims. He's not the father of Jews.
He's not the father of Christians.
That's in chapter 5:18. But the God of
Moses in Deuteronomy is a spiritual
father to the Israelites. So, how can
Muhammad be the prophet like Moses when
he contradicts Moses's view of God? Now,
so you got the point, right?
Moses is God in Deuteronomy 14 is a
father to Israel. Muhammad's God, Allah
is a father to no one. So, how can
Muhammad be the prophet like Moses?
Uh, good point. Now, go to Deuteronomy
32:6.
32.
32 verse 6.
Do you thus requite the Lord, oh foolish
people and unwise? Is not he thy father
that hath brought you? Has he not made
thee and established thee? Wait, so
again, Moses's God is the father of
Israel?
Wait, I can repeat that again. I can't
hear you. Moses is God. Is he the father
of Israel?
Um, yes. You're you're ding. You just
read it, dude. Dude, I know you young
guys, your attention, span is like zero.
Focus on what you're reading,
man. Read it one more time, homie.
Can you thus requite the Lord, oh
foolish people, and unwise? Is not he
thy father that has brought thee? Has he
not made thee and established thee? Is
he not thy father? So, you're like, um,
uh, uh, is that like a trick question?
Multiple choice. What does it say?
Uh it says it says is he not thy father?
So meaning so that means Moses's God is
a father to Israel, right?
[Music]
Uh I'm going bash my head
again. You're going to make me bash my
head. If you can't understand the King
James version, why you reading it, my
young brother? Read a translation you
can understand.
Okay. Do you want me to get my ESV?
Well, it's kind of too late right now.
The question it's, is he not your father
who bought thee? You're taking it as a
denial. No. It's like saying, "Hey, man.
Am I not the best looking apologist in
the
planet?" Why you laughing, bro? All
right. So, when it says, "Is he not thy
father who bought thee?" That is that
saying he's not your father or is it
saying he is your father who bought you?
He is your father. Exactly. So if the
King James is hard, go with a
translation until you work your way up
to the King James. I don't want you to
get stuck on a language and get
confused. I want you to understand it's
like it's a question where the question
itself has the answer like saying, "Hey
man, is Sam Shimon not the best
apologist on the planet?" See, when I
tell you that, I'm expecting you to say,
"Of course he is, because if you don't,
I'm going to block you."
Right.
Right. Okay. So do we get that is
Moses's God is a father to Israel,
right?
Yes. But Muhammad's Allah is a father to
no one. So how can Muhammad be the
prophet like Moses when he contradicts
the teaching of Moses?
Okay, good point. One more example and
then that's how you answer the question.
Okay. Okay. Go to Deuteronomy 24:es
1-4. And that's how you refute it. Says,
"Okay, if when you go to Deuteronomy
24, pay attention with me, Deuteronomy
24:4, pay attention to me and with me
before you read it, Derek, as you're
laughing at me and hurting my feelings."
Okay? Now, here's what you're going to
read. Moses's God is going to tell
Israel, "You can't do this. If you do
this, you're an abomination."
What you're trying to show from these
examples is for Moses to prophesy
Muhammad and Muhammad is the prophet
like Moses then he has to agree with the
teaching of Moses. But here are cases in
which Moses says something that Muhammad
contradicts. So he cannot be the prophet
like Moses. Right. Yeah. That's the
point I want you to keep in mind. So now
read for me Deuteronomy 24:es 104.
Uh when a man has taken a wife and
married her and it has come to pass that
she find no favor in his eyes because he
has found some uncleanliness in her then
let him write her a bill of divorcement
and give it in her hand and send her out
of his house. Okay, keep reading all the
way to four. Don't stop. And when and
and when she departed out of his house,
she may go and be another man's wife.
And if the latter husband hates her and
writes her a bill of divorcement and and
gives it to and gives it in her hand and
sends her out of his house, or if the
latter husband die, which took her to be
his wife, her former husband which sent
her away, may not take her again to be
his wife, after that she is defiled, for
that is an abomination before the Lord.
and thou shalt not cause the land to
sin, which the Lord thy God gives you
for inheritance. Now, explain what you
just read and make sure you read a
translation where you understand and
then work your way up to the King James.
God just said, "If a man divorces a
woman, pay attention, if a man divorces
a woman, she marries someone else,
that's someone else divorces her or
dies, she cannot go back to her first
husband. She
can't because if she does and the first
husband takes her back, this is
something disgusting to God. It defiles
the land. You can't do that, right?
Yeah. It's an abomination. Yes. So, what
is God saying? If you rem if you remarry
a wife you divorced
and she's been married to someone
else and that someone else died or
divorced her and you remarry her, you're
disgusting to God. Now remember this
verse in the Quran. Remember this verse
in the Quran. Chapter 2 of the Quran,
verse 230. Chapter 2, verse 230. Just
write that down. Are you ready? Yeah.
Got it? You got that now?
Yes. Okay. Now, let me tell you what
that verse says. Chapter 2 verse 230
says, "If a Muslim divorces a wife
irrevocably, he cannot take her back."
Let's he cannot man this connection.
Yeah. Guys, is it the connection okay?
Is it buffering bad for you guys? Is it
all
right? Is it all right or is it bad?
Hold on. Let me In chapter 2 verse 230.
It says the Muslim man divorces his
wife. He cannot take her back until she
marries
someone and that someone divorces her or
dies. Then only then he can take her
back. So if I divorce my wife, I'm a
Muslim, another Muslim man must marry
her, have with her, divorce her for me
to take her back. That Muslim man makes
her lawful for me. is called Muhandal.
Did you understand the problem with that
passage?
Yeah. Okay. What's the problem? A Muslim
man can only take back his ex-wife if
she marries someone else that someone
else has sex with her and divorces her,
then I can take her back. Do you
see? Do you see the contradiction?
Yeah. Because uh Yeah. Because God says,
"Do not take her back for uh that's an
abomination." But the Quran says to take
her back. You see? And how then how then
can Muhammad be the prophet like Moses?
Good point. He's not. Okay. So that's
how you destroy
it. Okay.